this is what would happen if you always  ate your boogers  the snot inside your nose is used to  protect you from harmful germs and  viruses  every time you breathe into your nose  you're inhaling a number of harmful  bacteria  but luckily your boogers trap any  harmful germs trying to come into your  system  so if you eat them you're essentially  putting all those germs and bacteria  back into your body and digesting them  this means you could get really sick  with  all kinds of different diseases  including influenza  and not only that but depending on how  much you pick your nose  you could also scratch the inside of  your nostrils  causing bleeding and other infections so  send this to a friend to get them to  stop picking their nose  and